Salut, moi c'est Guillaume Hachez. Bienvenue dans Septante Minutes Avec. Cet épisode, c'est avant tout un gros coup de bol.
En invitant Nadia Geerts et Philippe Van Parijs pour les épisodes précédents de Septante Minutes Avec, mon intention, c'était surtout de porter un regard sur le communautaire, sur les fractures qui divisent les Belges.
D'abord, d'un point de vue religieux avec Nadia Geerts et puis du point de vue linguistique avec Philippe Van Parijs.
Je me disais que ça ferait des sujets très intéressants pour le podcast et en les écoutant, j'étais assez content de ces deux épisodes.
D'ailleurs, vous avez été nombreux à me dire que ça vous avait plu aussi. Je pensais que c'était mission accomplie, que je pouvais tourner la page, qu'on avait fait le tour des fractures les plus importantes.
Et juste à ce moment-là, les gilets jaunes sont arrivés en Belgique, principalement en Wallonie. Et juste après ça,
septante-cinq mille personnes ont marché dans les rues de Bruxelles pour demander davantage de mesures pour lutter contre le réchauffement climatique.
Et d'ailleurs, certains ont choisi de les appeler les gilets verts. En voyant tout ça, j'ai compris qu'il y avait sans doute un sujet à traiter dans le podcast.
Je me posais de nombreuses questions et pour y répondre, j'ai contacté Alain Gerlache, journaliste politique à la RTBF, qui a accepté d'être mon invité.
Bon, déjà ça, c'est top, mais le vrai coup de bol, c'est qu'entre ce coup de fil et l'interview, on a eu une petite crise gouvernementale.
Et c'est comme ça que je me suis retrouvé à la RTBF, trois jours après que Charles Michel ait remis sa démission au Roi, pour interviewer un des plus grands journalistes politiques de la RTBF.
C'est pas mal, non ? Bon, évidemment, c'est nul pour le pays, mais moi, j'avoue que j'étais assez content.
Dans cet épisode, on parle donc de la crise gouvernementale des dernières semaines, mais pas seulement, puisqu'on parle aussi gilets jaunes, médias, presse et fake news.
C'est parti. Et bonjour à tous. Aujourd'hui, nous recevons Alain Gerlache, journaliste politique pour la RTBF, qui exerce également pour la VRT et pour De Morgen.
Vous êtes également enseignant à l'UCL. Alain Gerlache, bonjour.
Bonjour.
On va commencer par une question assez simple. Vous êtes journaliste depuis trente ans. Le journalisme, c'est un secteur avec une importante précarité de l'emploi.
On finit souvent par quitter le secteur par manque d'opportunités. Beaucoup de pigistes, d'après ce que j'ai compris, quittent le métier très tôt.
Si vous deviez faire une rétrospective sur votre carrière, comment est-ce que vous expliqueriez votre longévité, votre succès dans un secteur où il est dur de survivre ?
Alors, il y a des raisons personnelles et il y a des raisons institutionnelles.
La raison personnelle, c'est la passion pour ce travail,
pour le journalisme, pour les médias, pour la chose publique, l'envie d'essayer de rendre un certain nombre de choses complexes, intelligibles pour les gens,
une sorte d'interface entre,
je dirais, les décideurs,
de tout bord qu'ils soient, hein, et de toutes sortes qu'ils soient, et alors le public.
Oui, c'est-à-dire ceux qui ont des difficultés à trouver un emploi, sont peut-être moins passionnés que vous, c'est ça que vous voulez dire ?
Non, non, pas du tout, pas du tout.
D'ailleurs, j'allais y venir, pour le deuxième aspect de la question, c'est que j'ai eu la chance, évidemment, de travailler dans une entreprise qui est financée en grande partie par
les pouvoirs publics.
Et même si les pouvoirs publics n'ont pas énormément de moyens, en tout cas
la Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles, ben c'est vrai que la RTBF dispose quand même de revenus assez stables, et que comparativement à des médias privés, que ce soit dans les médias électroniques ou
ou dans la presse écrite, c'est vrai qu'il y a une certaine stabilité
et que ça a joué.
Donc, il y a des raisons personnelles, parce que si ça m'avait pas plu, ben j'aurais abandonné le travail.
Et il y a aussi des raisons institutionnelles et des raisons d'organisation qui font que cette entreprise peut quand même garantir une certaine stabilité à son personnel.
Oui, oui. On se souvient que juste avant de devenir Premier ministre, Yves Leterme avait dit en 2007, alors que vous étiez directeur général de la télévision pour la RTBF, il avait dit que la RTBF était un outil de propagande pour le CDH à l'époque.
Je me souviens également que, quand moi, j'étais en secondaire il y a une dizaine d'années, ma prof de français m'expliquait nonchalamment que la RTBF était plutôt à gauche et que RTL était plutôt à droite.
Est-ce qu'il y a une vérité derrière ces accusations ou bien est-ce que les gens se trompent complètement ?
Moi, je pense que c'est une grande tradition des services publics d'être considérés comme proches soit du pouvoir, hein, parce qu'il y a des gens qui rejettent en bloc, on le voit notamment,
en France, qui rejettent en bloc le service public en disant que le service public, puisqu'il est financé par l'État, il est toujours proche du pouvoir, quel qu'il soit.
Il y en a qui trouvent que le service public est d'office trop à gauche, d'autres qui trouvent qu'il est d'office trop à droite.
Je pense qu'on a toujours un prisme déformant vis-à-vis des médias qui fait que l'on est plus sensible à ce qui dérange un petit peu vos propres convictions.
Je pense qu'on voit plus facilement transparaître des convictions quand elles ne sont pas les vôtres. Et quand ce sont des choses qui vont dans votre sens, eh bien, ça vous paraît normal.
J'aurais tendance à dire que ce qui n'est pas objectif, c'est ce qui n'avalise pas mes positions et ce qui est objectif, c'est ce qui relaie mes opinions.
Donc, je pense qu'il faut prendre ça avec une certaine distance. C'est vrai que les médias doivent quand même, d'une certaine manière, déranger l'ordre établi, quel qu'il soit.
Ils doivent quand même poser un certain nombre de questions, ne pas censurer ce qui pourrait déstabiliser un peu telle ou telle institution, organisation, association ou autre.
Et donc voilà, ça peut en effet déranger. De là à avoir des grands complots, ça me paraît largement exagéré.
Mais quand même, c'était quand même dans la bouche du futur Premier ministre, donc la question méritait d'être posée.
C'est vrai, mais en même temps, il a aussi dit à une autre époque que la RTBF, c'était une radio, je vais pas citer son nom, mais une radio génocidaire au Rwanda, etc.
Oui oui, tout à fait, il a fait la comparaison.
Et donc, voilà, je pense que même un Premier ministre a le droit de temps en temps de dire quelque chose qui va sans doute un peu au-delà du bon sens.
Et bon, c'est la période des fêtes et de Noël, donc je suis généreux et je fais preuve de mansuétude.
Si ce qu'exposait ma prof de français il y a dix ans était trop schématique, comment est-ce que vous définiriez alors la différence entre RTL et la RTBF ?
Est-ce que vous auriez pu travailler pour RTL ?
Alors, j'aurais pu travailler pour RTL parce que j'estime que ce n'est pas parce qu'un média est privé qu'il est nécessairement de mauvaise qualité.
Toute la presse écrite est privée et il y a des journaux de qualité. Et qualité, ça ne veut pas dire nécessairement de s'adresser à un public averti, cultivé, qui a fait des études, etc.
Un média de qualité, pour moi, c'est un média qui parvient à s'adresser à son public quel qu'il soit et qui ne transige pas sur une certaine exigence journalistique.
Donc, on peut être un média populaire de qualité et on peut être un média populaire de mauvaise qualité. On peut être un média qui s'adresse à un public qui a davantage de niveau
scolaire, par exemple, et le faire mal.
Donc, ce n'est pas parce qu'un média est privé que je n'aurais pas pu travailler pour lui. D'ailleurs, je travaille pour un journal flamand qui est un journal privé et ça ne me dérange pas du tout.
La question n'était pas privé versus public, c'était RTL versus la RTBF, précisément.
Mais comme c'est une des différences, je pense qu'il faut pouvoir préciser ça.
Maintenant, c'est vrai que par rapport à ce qui, moi, m'intéresse dans l'info,
c'est-à-dire plutôt tout ce qui est explication approfondie, le fait de pouvoir se donner le temps d'aller plus loin dans un certain nombre de dossiers.
C'est vrai que c'est davantage ce qui m'intéresse plutôt que la couverture de l'actualité, dans toutes ses variétés, y compris les faits divers, etc.
Ce qui n'est pas trop ce qui m'intéresse. Et donc le service public correspond mieux à mes attentes. Mais je n'ai aucun mépris pour
pour RTL et pour les gens qui y travaillent dans des conditions qui sont souvent, il faut le reconnaître, plus difficiles, et singulièrement depuis leur dernier plan d'économie qu'à la RTBF.
Vous parlez du service public. Je sais que depuis quelques années, vous apparaissez également sur le plateau de la VRT.
Donc j'ai envie de vous poser la question, mais quelle est la différence, d'après vous, entre le service public flamand et le service public francophone ?
Est-ce que vous ressentez une différence de traitement en termes de journalisme ?
Je dirais que la différence, elle est surtout que l'un est francophone et l'autre est flamand. Et ce n'est pas une question de langue, mais c'est vrai que ce sont des mondes quand même qui ont leurs médias, qui ont leurs repères différents.
Et donc, forcément, il y a une tonalité différente dans le traitement de l'information. Mais vous savez, même si vous regardez TF1 ou France 2, ils ne font pas exactement la même information que nous.
Si vous regardez la BBC, c'est aussi autre chose. Les médias, ils sont inscrits dans une réalité nationale, socioculturelle, avec un cadre de référence, etc.
Et oui, il y a des différences entre la RTBF et la VRT, mais ce sont des différences qui tiennent surtout au fait que ce sont deux mondes qui ont deux cultures différentes.
Ça ne veut pas dire que c'est radicalement différent, hein. Je pense que si je devais subitement travailler dans un média japonais ou uruguayen, la différence serait encore beaucoup plus grande.
Donc, je ne tiens pas à dire que ce sont deux mondes que tout oppose, mais c'est vrai qu'il y a des différences.
Oui. Si vous deviez en citer quelques-unes, qu'est-ce qui vous apparaît ?
Mais d'abord, la VRT a décidé vraiment de travailler, en télévision notamment, sur des formats qui sont des formats assez longs,
dans l'information, avec des journaux qui peuvent ne choisir que l'un ou l'autre sujet et puis le développer longuement.
Il y a aussi, et c'est sans doute plus anglo-saxon, une tradition, depuis ces dernières années, de talk-show de l'information où l'on fait se rencontrer des gens de façons diverses sur différents sujets.
Voilà, il y a quand même un certain nombre de différences qui correspondent aux choix de l'entreprise et aux attentes du public.
C'est ça. Mais par exemple, vous donniez l'exemple des talk-shows. On peut vous voir de temps en temps sur le plateau de Afspraak sur Canvas.
La RTBF, quant à elle, a choisi de ne plus faire une émission politique le dimanche. Il y en a une, je crois, le mercredi en deuxième partie de soirée.
Vous exprimiez tout à l'heure une préférence pour un média qui prend son temps d'aller en profondeur. On a un petit peu le sentiment, en tout cas au niveau de la télévision, que la RTBF s'éloigne un petit peu de ça.
Alors, je n'ai pas de responsabilité de direction à la RTBF, je n'en ai plus.
Oui.
Et donc je ne peux pas parler en son nom. Le créneau du dimanche midi était occupé depuis les années 60 par une émission politique.
Entre les années 60 et aujourd'hui, beaucoup de choses-
...ont changé dans les habitudes des gens. Donc c'est pas en soi surprenant qu'on déplace les choses. Il y a aussi l'influence des émissions françaises.
Là aussi, il y a eu pendant tout un temps une émission d'information le dimanche midi et puis ils les ont déplacées en soirée.
Et je sais qu'en termes d'audience, l'émission du mercredi soir fait davantage d'audience que n'en faisait l'émission du dimanche midi.
Et sans avoir fait de concessions sur le niveau d'exigence journalistique. Donc, ça ne me paraît pas insupportable-
Très bien.
...d'avoir fait ce choix et ça ne me paraît pas du tout un pari perdu. Ça me paraît plutôt un pari réussi.
En 99, vous aviez fait le choix de quitter temporairement le journalisme pour devenir porte-parole du Premier ministre Guy Verhofstadt.
Vous êtes ensuite revenu à la RTBF comme directeur général de la télévision pendant quatre ans, on le disait.
Quand un proche collaborateur du Premier ministre belge est chargé de diriger La Une et La Deux alors que ce Premier ministre est encore au pouvoir,
il faut tout de même s'interroger au moins un petit peu sur l'indépendance du service public.
On l'évoquait tout à l'heure. Est-ce que vous estimez qu'il y a pu y avoir problème à ce moment-là ?
Alors, je peux imaginer qu'il y a eu, pas qu'il y a pu avoir, qu'il y a eu un problème de perception, comme on dit.
Et je ne nie pas du tout que la perception, c'est important. Mais il faut savoir que dans la structure de la RTBF, le directeur de la télé à l'époque, parce qu'entre-temps, la-
Les choses ont changé.
...la structure a changé, mais fondamentalement, ça ne modifie pas ce principe. Le directeur de la télévision n'a aucune autorité sur l'information.
Il y avait un directeur de l'information qui était hiérarchiquement égal au directeur de la télévision, qui n'avait pas d'ordre à recevoir.
Et donc le directeur de la télévision, et celui qui m'a suivi aussi, tout comme celui qui m'a précédé, n'avait aucun pouvoir,
ni sur l'engagement des journalistes, ni sur les promotions des journalistes, ni non plus sur la désignation des responsables et encore moins sur les informations traitées journalistiquement.
Le directeur de la télévision était quelqu'un qui, à l'époque, s'occupait des programmes et de la gestion générale de la télévision hors information.
Donc autant on peut comprendre qu'il ait pu y avoir un problème de perception, autant il n'y a pas eu, à aucun moment, un problème d'influence-
D'accord.
...sur l'information, puisque la question ne se posait pas. Tout autre chose aurait été
si, comme d'autres ont pu faire ce choix, j'étais revenu comme journaliste, mais je ne suis jamais redevenu journaliste politique après 1999.
J'ai occupé ces fonctions. Après, j'ai occupé d'autres fonctions internationales. Et puis je suis revenu dans le journalisme par le biais
de sujets liés aux médias et à la communication, à la communication politique aussi, certes, mais plus sur le biais du commentaire, mais jamais sur le biais du journalisme politique comme tel.
Je n'ai jamais, après 99, refait des choses que j'avais faites avant. Et que je sache, personne ne m'a critiqué pour avoir refait, à la demande d'ailleurs de l'entreprise, ce n'est pas moi qui l'ai sollicitée,
des séquences, des émissions qui étaient liées à la communication ou aux médias, qui étaient des choses pour lesquelles j'avais une certaine expertise.
Oui. Est-ce que quand vous apparaissez sur un plateau, par exemple, de After Action, les talk-shows, en tant que commentateur politique, est-ce que-- bon, je pose la question sans avoir une idée de la réponse.
Est-ce que ce ne serait pas intéressant de préciser : « Tiens, j'ai collaboré avec l'Open VLD par le passé. »
Alors, je n'ai pas collaboré avec l'Open VLD.
Oui, avec le, pardon, le Premier ministre Guy Verhofstadt.
J'étais porte-parole d'un Premier ministre où il y avait, dans un gouvernement où il y avait des libéraux, des socialistes et des écologistes, ce qui donne déjà une plus grande palette.
Ce n'est pas à moi de décider de la manière dont je suis présenté. Je rappelle quand même que j'ai quitté cette fonction il y a maintenant-
Quinze ans.
...quinze ans, presque seize, et que, bon, moi, je ne fais pas mystère. Mon parcours est connu. Je ne le cache pas.
Peut-être pas connu de tous.
Mais je n'ai pas non plus, à ce moment-là, arrêté la réflexion sur tel et tel sujet.
Et je suppose que si on continue à m'inviter, parce que c'est pas moi qui sollicite les invitations, si on continue à m'inviter, c'est parce qu'on estime que
ma contribution, et je le dis en toute modestie, peut apporter une certaine plus-value.
Certainement.
La précision de ce passé, duquel je ne fais pas mystère, hein, c'est que c'est connu, pourrait au contraire me donner l'image de quelqu'un qui parle encore au nom d'eux, ce que je n'ai plus fait depuis longtemps.
Moi, je dis toujours : on peut faire plusieurs métiers dans sa vie à condition de ne pas vouloir les faire en même temps.
Et personnellement, je n'ai rien à cacher.
Oui. Donc, on le disait, vous étiez directeur général de la télévision entre 2003 et 2007. Ça veut dire que vous étiez aux commandes lors de la diffusion du très controversé faux JT
Bye Bye Belgium en 2006, dans lequel vous apparaissiez d'ailleurs.
Quelque part, ce Bye Bye Belgium pouvait exister vraiment qu'à cette époque, parce que c'était encore une époque où le média télé était roi.
Depuis, on a connu une période de transition où l'information s'est vraiment décentralisée avec les réseaux sociaux, Twitter, Reddit, Facebook, etc.
Aujourd'hui, on a vu il y a quelques semaines un article dans le journal Le Soir qui disait qu'il n'y avait plus qu'un tiers des jeunes adultes qui regardaient encore le média télé.
Est-ce que vous regrettez cette époque, Alain Gerlache, où le média télé était roi ? Est-ce que c'était mieux avant ?
Non, je ne regrette pas parce que voilà, c'est une évolution. Tout comme quand la télévision est apparue, je ne pense pas qu'il y avait des gens qui devaient regretter que la radio et la presse écrite ne soient plus toutes puissantes.
Et quand la radio est apparue, ben voilà, c'est une évolution. On ne peut pas arrêter le temps, on ne peut pas remonter en arrière.
Ce ne sont que des supports, des supports qui peuvent évidemment avoir leur grammaire, leur richesse, leur créativité, etc.
Mais voilà, c'est une évolution qu'on ne peut pas arrêter. La technologie a toujours influencé l'évolution du journalisme.
Il faut bien le savoir. On n'a pas attendu Internet pour que la technologie influence la façon dont on faisait du journalisme.
Quand on a inventé la télévision, ben forcément, ça a eu un impact sur le journalisme aussi. L'essentiel, c'est quand même que, en tout cas du point de vue de l'information, c'est que le journalisme puisse continuer à exister.
Et donc moi, ma préoccupation n'est pas de savoir si les gens ont accès à une information de qualité.
Et on sait bien que c'est de plus en plus difficile et que c'est de plus en plus risqué maintenant de vouloir se lancer
dans ce genre d'activité à cause des bouleversements économiques, à cause de la place prise par les réseaux sociaux,
à cause de cette espèce d'impact que peuvent avoir aussi un certain nombre de campagnes diverses vis-à-vis des médias, etc.
Mais moi, ce qui m'intéresse, c'est de savoir si les différents publics, par rapport aux plateformes où ils sont présents, peuvent continuer à avoir une information de qualité.
C'est ça l'enjeu. Mais la nostalgie de la télévision toute-puissante, non. Ben voilà, ça a eu un temps, ben ça ne l'a plus.
Ben voilà, il faut réimaginer autre chose.
Je pose la question dans le contexte où, voilà, il y a vingt ans, toute la Belgique, toute la Belgique francophone, entre guillemets, était devant son écran de télé à 19 heures 30 pour regarder le JT, pour écouter François de Rugyode.
Le fait qu'aujourd'hui, ce ne soit plus vraiment l'église au milieu du village et qu'on puisse avoir des sources d'information qui ne sont pas toujours très nettes.
Je pense aux fake news, je pense aux réseaux sociaux, à l'information qui est déformée, aux... Il y avait une étude qui montrait que 60 % des Américains ne lisaient que le headline, le titre de l'article.
Dans ce contexte-là,
est-ce qu'on n'est pas tenté de regretter cette époque où l'information était plus centralisée et on était plus sûr, grâce à un service public qui fait normalement bien son travail, d'avoir une population bien informée ?
Est-ce qu'aujourd'hui, on n'a pas perdu au change, finalement, comment la population peut être désinformée à présent plus facilement grâce aux réseaux sociaux, aux fake news, etc. ?
Alors, on est sûrement dans une période plus complexe, mais comme je viens de le dire, on n'a pas le choix. C'est comme ça.
C'est l'évolution des technologies, c'est l'évolution du public.
Vous n'êtes pas du genre à regretter.
Mais je veux dire, ce serait une perte de temps que d'être nostalgique et de regretter. La question aujourd'hui n'est pas de savoir si c'était mieux au temps où la télévision était toute-puissante.
La question aujourd'hui, c'est de savoir comment, dans l'environnement technologique, dans l'environnement social, dans l'environnement culturel aujourd'hui, on essaye de préserver une information qui est considérée comme
fiable, accessible,
qui permet aux gens de connaître le monde qui les entoure, d'en saisir les enjeux et de le faire avec une rigueur qui fait en sorte qu'un certain nombre de manipulations ne puissent pas arriver à leur fin.
C'est ça l'enjeu. Et on est sûrement actuellement encore dans une période de grande instabilité, dont j'espère que l'on finira par sortir.
Ce ne sera jamais simple parce que je pense non plus qu'il ne faut pas idéaliser hein. Au moment où la télévision était toute-puissante, il y avait aussi pas mal de critiques sur l'information.
Quand il y avait une seule chaîne, ben c'est vrai qu'il y avait
des critiques là-dessus. Quand RTL lance vraiment son journal en communauté française, ils appellent-- le slogan de leur campagne de pub, c'est L'Autre Vérité, ce qui montrerait bien que,
il y avait une remise en cause d'une certaine hégémonie.
Donc voilà, ce sont toutes des choses qui sont essentiellement du passé et il me semble que les défis aujourd'hui, c'est d'essayer de repenser l'information, de repenser le journalisme,
d'une manière qui correspond à ses habitudes, d'une manière qui fait en sorte que elle lui parle et lui donne le goût d'une information de qualité, d'une exigence, parce que c'est ça qui est la meilleure réponse
à toutes les fausses informations et à tous les complots.
Oui. La réponse qu'on donne généralement, voilà, c'est la période de transition que vous évoquiez, cette période où le fake news est un petit peu roi.
La réponse qu'on donne généralement à ça, c'est : on va demander aux plateformes, à Facebook et à Twitter, de faire appel à des grandes publications comme Le Monde, Le Soir, le New York Times pour faire du fact checking.
Est-ce que ça vous paraît être une solution viable ?
Alors, je pense qu'il faut de toute façon faire du fact checking. Donc la vérification des faits. Bah la vérification des faits, de toute façon, c'est quand même dans l'ADN du journalisme, hein.
On n'a pas attendu d'avoir l'expression américaine fact checking pour vérifier les faits. Mais on comprend ce que ça veut dire ici.
C'est vraiment essayer de vérifier la véracité d'un certain nombre soit de déclarations, soit de nouvelles qui sont diffusées par des sources sûres ou moins sûres.
C'est de faire en sorte d'essayer d'expliquer, pardon, la réalité d'un certain nombre de choses qui sont mises en avant, et qui sont diffusées par tous les canaux que l'on connaît maintenant.
À mon avis, c'est indispensable, mais ce n'est pas suffisant parce que ben le problème des fausses nouvelles, des complots, etc., c'est que ça parle davantage aux gens que—
Ça plaît.
Que la réalité, que la réalité des faits. On a davantage tendance à vouloir croire ce qui avalise en quelque sorte soit vos présupposés, soit vos opinions, soit votre perception des choses.
Et donc, oui, il faut essayer de faire en sorte que
cette vérification des faits, ce fact checking, s'inscrive dans une stratégie globale de lutte contre les fausses informations, de lutte contre le complotisme et de la certification des sources d'information.
Et donc ça veut dire qu'il faut en effet que
les gens soient de plus en plus conscients que il faut quand même toujours mieux essayer de regarder la réalité telle qu'elle est plutôt que d'essayer de faire en sorte que
on ne regarde que la télé, que la réalité telle qu'on la voudrait.
Mais c'est un travail compliqué et ça prendra—
C'est très complexe.
Très, très, très longtemps. Mais c'est une exigence démocratique à plein de niveaux.
Il y a un site belge en particulier que vous avez dans le collimateur. D'ailleurs, sur Twitter, vous essayez de ne même plus le nommer.
Je parle de Nordpresse.be. C'est un site qui, au début, avait peut-être des allures de Gorafi avec un côté un petit peu humoristique.
Mais les années passant, son créateur a fait le choix de publier des choses de plus en plus crédibles, de plus en plus clivantes.
D'ailleurs, il l'avoue lui-même que c'est une stratégie qui lui permet de renforcer ses revenus publicitaires.
Est-ce que c'est bien légal, un site comme ça, qui fait des fake news soi-disant humoristiques pour dire, par exemple, que Brigitte Macron a acheté des bijoux à 10 000 euros ce mois-ci ?
Est-ce qu'on est bien dans le cadre de la légalité quand on fait ça ?
Alors moi, ce n'est pas ce genre de site qui m'intéresse. Ce qui m'intéresse, c'est de lutter contre les fake news.
Je considère que ces sites, ce type de sites, participent aux fake news. Pas le Gorafi, parce que dans le Gorafi, il y a un—
L'absurdité.
Parti pris,
humoristique et il y a du talent, mais quand il n'y a pas de talent, il ne reste que les fake news. Et donc il y a un problème là, de talent, de positionnement qui fait que soit on sourit de l'actualité,
soit on essaye au contraire de faire en sorte de brouiller les pistes.
Et le pire est évidemment quand après, on donne des leçons de journalisme et de fake news. Ce n'est pas non plus Le Canard enchaîné, donc ce ne sont pas des sites satiriques.
Le Canard enchaîné est un cana-- est un journal, un canard, dont l'information est traitée dans la forme sur un site humoristique, là aussi avec de l'humour et avec du talent.
Et c'est déjà une différence fondamentale. Mais les informations du Canard enchaîné sont des informations qui, le plus souvent, sont fiables et qui sont souvent exclusives.
Ils amènent des choses qui ne sont pas connues et ils font un véritable travail journalistique d'information.
Donc, on est aux antipodes. Tous ces sites, et il y en a d'autres hein, tous ces sites qui essayent de se présenter comme satiriques, mais qui aboutissent à brouiller encore les pistes, eh bien, pour moi, doivent être combattus. Et—
Combattus sur le plan légal.
Je n'ai pas de vindicte personnelle. Je ne fais pas campagne. Bon, il se fait que ça se situe chez nous et donc forcément, c'est normal qu'on en parle, mais, à chacun de se faire son opinion.
En tout cas, je ne réponds jamais au niveau des attaques personnelles que je reçois quand je formule des critiques qui sont des critiques de fond.
J'essaye de poser un problème, de faire des critiques de fond et je constate que en réponse, je n'ai jamais autre chose, soit de la part des gens qui gèrent ce site, soit de la part d'un certain nombre de ses supporters.
Je n'ai jamais autre chose que des attaques personnelles et des insultes. Eh bien, il me semble que entre le fond et les insultes, le public doit pouvoir choisir.
Oui, ça fait également penser, hein, la question de la relation entre la vérité et la réalité, ça fait également penser à ce que disait Barack Obama il y a un an.
C'est que si on regarde aux États-Unis, si on regarde Fox News ou si on regarde MSNBC, on ne vit pas sur la même planète parce qu'il y a un traitement de l'information qui est foncièrement différent.
Et aux États-Unis, corrigez-moi si je me trompe, mais je pense qu'ils n'ont pas de CSA, ils n'ont pas de haute autorité pour condamner le mensonge télévisé.
Finalement, comment est-ce qu'on sort de ce problème-là quand il n'y a pas une autorité, quand il n'y a pas quelqu'un pour condamner un Fox News qui dit que Paris est rempli de terroristes ou que sais-je ?
Alors,
chez nous, c'est plutôt le Conseil de déontologie journalistique qui gère ce genre de choses, qui est une instance donc paritaire, qui comprend un certain nombre de gens issus des médias et un certain nombre de gens
issus de la société civile, même si on y trouve quand même pas mal d'anciens journalistes, ce qui
est peut-être un peu
aussi une ambiguïté qu'il faudrait un jour dépasser, parce que ça donne peut-être un poids plus important aux journalistes dans la structure que ce qui était censé être prévu au départ.
Mais peu importe, le principe qui a été pris, c'est que les médias essayent de gérer entre eux leurs problèmes déontologiques et que c'est eux,
et pas la justice, par exemple, qui sont amenés à traiter de questions déontologiques.
Sauf évidemment lorsqu'on sort carrément du cadre journalistique et que un certain nombre de choses pourraient être du ressort de la justice, mais je vais pas entrer dans ce détail.
Ça, c'est la vision que nous avons en Europe. La vision qu'on a aux États-Unis est en fait, oui, très différente.
Et à partir du moment où il n'y a pas d'instance de contrôle ou de régulation, eh bien c'est le public qui doit en effet décider.
C'est au public de choisir les médias qu'il suit. C'est au public de s'inquiéter de telle ou telle dérive.
Si cette dérive l'arrange, ben oui, il y a un problème, mais je ne vois pas comment on peut le résoudre dans le cadre américain tel qu'il existe actuellement.
C'est vrai qu'à partir du moment où il y a des médias qui, sciemment, décident de donner des informations erronées ou qui sont l'objet de campagnes de la part d'adversaires
ou de partis politiques qui estiment qu'ils ne servent pas leurs intérêts, il y a en effet un problème.
La seule chose que je peux vous répondre, moi qui ne suis pas américain, c'est qu'en effet, je préfère la culture européenne que l'on a dans ce domaine.
Oui. Les fake news, c'est également quelque chose qui a pu impacter occasionnellement le mouvement des gilets jaunes.
J'aimerais qu'on revienne un petit peu sur ce mouvement. Le journal L'Écho annonçait il y a quelques semaines, chiffres à l'appui, que le pouvoir d'achat des travailleurs temps plein
les plus pauvres avaient augmenté entre quatre point cinq et six pour cent.
Et c'est assez perturbant parce que la gauche francophone et les gilets jaunes se plaignent justement d'une baisse du pouvoir d'achat et d'un gouvernement antisocial.
Finalement, mais qu'est-ce qu'il faut comprendre ? Qui a raison ? Est-ce que c'est de nouveau une question de relation avec la vérité, avec la perception ?
C'est en effet une question qui est liée à, d'une part, la vérité et d'autre part, la perception. Alors, la perception de son niveau social
et de ses possibilités, elle n'est pas uniquement liée à l'information que l'on reçoit dans les journaux, à la radio, à la télévision ou sur les réseaux sociaux.
Elle est liée à tout un certain nombre de facteurs que des sociologues peuvent sans doute beaucoup mieux expliquer que moi, qui sont justement l'attrait, par exemple, que peuvent représenter un certain nombre de dépenses.
Et donc la publicité est évidemment engagée. À partir du moment où le monde publicitaire rend
ou fait passer l'idée qu'il est normal de se payer telle ou telle chose et qu'on peut pas se les payer, eh bien, il peut y avoir un sentiment, en effet, un sentiment d'exclusion.
Donc, forcément, le ressenti peut en effet être inquiétant. De même,
si l'on constate que tel poste qui est important subit une forte augmentation, ben on percevra peut-être moins l'impact que ça peut avoir par rapport à une hausse de pouvoir d'achat plus générale.
Et puis ce sont des moyennes aussi, les hausses de pouvoir d'achat. Il se peut que telle ou telle catégorie, c'est pas uniforme, soit davantage pénalisée, que d'autres soient davantage favorisées.
Et puis, il y a l'effet d'entraînement. Donc, il y a les réalités statistiques et puis il y a aussi les réalités qui sont vécues par les différentes personnes.
La perception, ce n'est pas simplement une façon de dire que ce qui est ressenti est faux. C'est aussi le fait que chacun a son,
son environnement à soi et ben la situation sociale de telle ou telle famille n'est peut-être pas celle d'une autre.
En France, le mouvement des gilets jaunes a démarré sur la question de la fiscalité, les accises sur le diesel et ainsi de suite.
On a vu ensuite apparaître des revendications qui étaient plus liées à la démocratie, aux relations tumultueuses avec le pouvoir.
C'est que le côté un petit peu princier de Emmanuel Macron n'aide sans doute pas. En Belgique, c'est sans doute aussi un petit peu le côté des petits jeux de politiciens qu'ils font entre eux.
Une réponse qui a été amenée à ce problème-là et qui fait beaucoup parler d'elle chez les gilets jaunes, c'est ben, la démocratie directe, les votations, le référendum d'initiative citoyenne.
Et on remarque que ça commence à prendre chez les politiciens, à droite comme à gauche. En tout cas, on en parle un petit peu, sans rejeter tout à fait cette idée.
Est-ce que vous estimez que ça pourrait arriver dans notre système politique, la démocratie directe ?
Alors, la démocratie directe, c'est un peu une tarte à la crème hein, parce que c'est une expression, mais après, quand il s'agit de définir ou de voir comment on s'organise,
bon, moi, je ne crois pas que l'on va pouvoir organiser des espèces d'assemblées libres permanentes dans notre pays pour décider de la politique à mener.
Il faut quand même être réaliste. Jusqu'à nouvel ordre,
une dose importante de démocratie représentative, c'est-à-dire le fait de voter pour des gens que l'on délègue pour prendre un certain nombre de décisions ensemble hein, sous forme de,
de compromis souvent, je pense que ça va rester indispensable pendant un certain temps.
Et aussi parce que c'est à la fois plus pratique, mais c'est aussi parce que c'est une forme de reflet et de prise en compte de la diversité.
Le paradoxe chez les gilets jaunes, c'est qu'ils n'ont pas arrêté de se présenter comme le peuple, mais en même temps, quand on creuse un petit peu, ils ont des avis qui sont extrêmement différents.
Et tant mieux d'ailleurs. Ce n'est pas parce que subitement, on s'oppose à un pouvoir que l'on est tous d'accord. Et pour moi, la démocratie représentative a aussi l'avantage de refléter cette diversité, de refléter ce pluralisme,
de faire en sorte que des opinions différentes soient prises en compte.
Maintenant, est-ce que pour autant, il ne faut pas, à côté ou au sein de cette démocratie représentative, introduire aussi une dose,
de référendum, une dose de participation populaire, une dose de consultation de la population sur des sujets sur lesquels elle est amenée à s'exprimer, je dirais, en connaissance de cause ?
Ah sûrement. Je pense que c'est une des pistes qu'il faut envisager pour faire en sorte que la démocratie, ce ne soit pas simplement vote et tais-toi.
Parce que c'est justement quand c'est vote et tais-toi que l'on est obligé de s'exprimer d'une manière qui est disruptive, pour employer un mot à la mode, voire violente.
Je n'excuse rien, mais j'essaie d'expliquer.
Et c'est vrai que la consultation populaire, pour employer un terme général, le référendum, permettrait à certains moments,
de faire en sorte que la population s'exprime pour un certain nombre de choses en en percevant bien aussi tous les enjeux.
Et là, on revient à la nécessité de l'information,
d'une information impartiale, d'une information de qualité, etc. Parce qu'on a quand même un exemple
de référendum où les gens ont voté sans connaître les conséquences de leur vote et en tout cas sans connaître les conséquences du vote qui a été majoritaire,
avec évidemment beaucoup de manipulation.
Et on voit bien les problèmes que cela pose jusqu'à aujourd'hui, c'est le Brexit. Le Brexit est sans doute le contre-exemple d'un référendum,
où la population vote en connaissance de cause et qui permet de déboucher sur une sorte de,
de rénovation démocratique.
Oui, tout à fait.
C'est une faillite démocratique.
La campagne du Brexit s'est fait très clairement, au moins en partie, influencée par des actions du GRU russe, des fake news, voilà, très, très manipulatrices.
Quelque chose qui frappe également avec les gilets jaunes, mais pas seulement, c'est aussi un mépris assez récurrent pour la presse, pour les médias.
D'où est-ce que ça vient, d'après vous ?
Alors, ça vient d'un phénomène parisien, d'un phénomène français qui est lié à ce qui peut apparaître à certains moments comme une presse trop parisienne, trop proche du pouvoir, trop élitiste, arrogante peut-être.
C'est vrai qu'à force de voir toujours les mêmes éditorialistes dans toutes les émissions de télé,
qui pérorent et qui expliquent au bon peuple ce qu'il doit penser, ça finit quand même par donner l'impression que ben la réalité n'est pas prise en compte.
Nous sommes dans une situation quand même différente en Belgique hein. Nous avons beaucoup moins, chez nous ces espèces de gourous médiatiques qui ont un avis sur tout,
que l'on voit tout le temps, tout le temps, tout le temps, sur toutes les chaînes, plusieurs fois par semaine, qui font la leçon au monde entier.
Je pense que c'est beaucoup moins présent chez nous, même si ça commence quand même un peu hein. Il y a davantage de commentaires politiques et je le dis d'autant plus volontiers que j'y participe aussi,
mais il me semble que nous sommes quand même dans une structure,
qui est beaucoup moins élitiste et beaucoup moins arrogante chez nous.
Donc, je pense que là,
le danger est moins grand. Maintenant, c'est vrai qu'au-delà de ça,
il y a des gens qui estiment en effet que on est dans une structure où les médias ne sont pas de nature à donner une information correcte, fiable, honnête, pluraliste, parce qu'ils sont à la solde d'un certain nombre de pouvoirs.
Ça, ça existe quand même chez nous, c'est vrai.
Oui, on a le sentiment que chez les gilets jaunes, il y a un petit peu cette,
de nouveau, cette information décentralisée, un petit peu, je vais employer un terme d'informaticien, mais peer to peer, où on a, voilà, des,
des gilets jaunes qui enfilent leur gilet, qui se font une vidéo face caméra, qui la publient sur le réseau pour, voilà, exprimer un discours orienté politiquement ou bien pour organiser une révolte quelque part.
Et on a le sentiment que, de nouveau, c'est ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure, il y a un...
Un refus d'accepter une information qui a une plus grande volonté d'être objective, de refléter la réalité, une grande préférence pour, voilà, le—
Mais les gilets jaunes sont dans une stratégie d'opposition. Ils ont un message à faire passer. Ils sont dans une stratégie de mouvement social et dans une stratégie de mouvement social, on est en conflit.
Et donc forcément, on a envie de promouvoir un certain nombre de thèmes qui vont favoriser le point de vue que l'on défend.
Donc ça, ça me paraît cohérent. C'est dans tous les conflits sociaux, y compris dans des conflits syndicaux, tout comme en effet les patrons, voire le gouvernement a envie aussi de faire passer ses, ses positions.
On doit pas attendre des mouvements sociaux qu'ils fassent une information autre que la défense de leur point de vue.
Ce qui ne veut pas dire mentir évidemment, mais qui est mettre l'accent sur un certain nombre de choses que l'on veut mettre en avant.
Mais ça montre bien que dans ce genre de situation, on a absolument besoin, justement, de médias indépendants, de journalistes,
compétents qui font une information de, de qualité qui doit permettre aux, aux, aux gens de se faire, de se faire leur opinion.
Venons-en à la crise politique qui a touché le pays ces dernières semaines. On le rappelle rapidement, la N-VA a donc quitté le gouvernement sous prétexte qu'ils refusaient de signer le fameux traité de Marrakech.
Une fois dehors, ils ont adopté un discours
assez radical en déclarant par exemple que Charles Michel devait devenir leur marionnette et en refusant de signer le budget, à moins que le gouvernement ne fasse un pas soit vers le confédéralisme, soit vers des élections anticipées.
Le gouvernement de Charles Michel a refusé ce deal. Une motion de méfiance a été introduite au Parlement par sp.a, PS et cosignée par Ecolo-Groen.
Charles Michel a décidé à ce moment-là de présenter sa démission au roi avant même que la motion ne soit votée. Alain Gerlache, de nombreux observateurs politiques estiment qu'on est reparti pour une période d'immobilisme
sans vrai gouvernement fédéral avant très très très longtemps.
Est-ce que vous partagez cet avis ?
Alors moi, j'essaye de regarder les choses avec un minimum de sang-froid. C'est vrai qu'il y a ce traumatisme de la crise des cinq cent quarante et un jours et on se dit : c'est parti.
C'est vrai aussi qu'il n'y a plus en Belgique de gouvernement qui a eu la majorité soit en Flandre, soit en Wallonie, depuis déjà huit ans.
Alors, c'est pas obligatoire, mais c'est quand même toujours un peu mieux dans un pays comme la Belgique que les gouvernements soient soutenus par les, les deux grandes communautés qui, qui peuvent s'y retrouver.
Il y a déjà tellement de défiance par rapport au monde politique que c'est sans doute mieux qu'on ne démarre pas déjà en étant minoritaire.
Mais soyons de bon compte. Ce qui est sur la table maintenant, c'est soit un vote en mai
où l'on votera à la fois pour les fédérales, les régionales et l'Europe, soit un vote au printemps à une date à fixer et puis de nouveau pour les fédérales et, et ensuite en mai.
Ça ne changera pas grand-chose. Ça ne changera pas grand-chose. Pourquoi ? Mais parce qu'il me paraît, à moi, très difficile
alors que les partis seraient en campagne pour les élections régionales et européennes pendant ce temps de former un, un, un gouvernement au niveau fédéral.
Donc même si on anticipe, ça ne veut pas dire qu'on aura un gouvernement plus tôt. Maintenant, ce qui se passera au-delà de, au-delà de mai, oui, on peut agiter les peurs, etc.
Ben, on n'en sait rien en fait. Il y a un certain nombre d'indicateurs qui, aujourd'hui, permettent de supposer que ce ne sera pas facile, mais fondamentalement, il n'y a aucun moyen de démontrer que ça va prendre
un an et demi de former un, un nouveau gouvernement.
On se souvient qu'après avoir décidé de se retirer du gouvernement, le terme deux en deux mille dix, Alexander De Croo l'avait payé assez cher aux urnes.
Qui payera cette fois pour la chute du gouvernement ? Est-ce que, est-ce que la N-VA en bénéficie, d'après vous
? Parce qu'elle utilise quand même le chaos politique actuel comme argument pour justifier, voilà, cette démocratie ne fonctionne pas, le confédéralisme est la seule solution, ainsi de suite.
Alors, la N-VA a l'avantage de pouvoir toujours jouer sur deux tableaux. Quand elle fonctionne à l'intérieur du système belge et qu'elle le fait de façon correcte,
en tout cas techniquement, avec des ministres qui connaissent leur dossier, etc.
Comme ça a pu être le cas de Jan Jambon, par exemple, et qui ont une communication personnelle qui ne suscite pas de désapprobation particulière, contrairement à son collègue Theo Francken. Voilà.
Sauf peut-être le cas de la marionnette, il y a quelques jours.
Et donc, oui, mais je parle de quand ils étaient, de quand ils étaient au gouvernement.
Oui, tout à fait, oui.
Bon, c'est une possibilité, mais ils ont toujours la possibilité aussi, quand ça ne va pas, de dire : Ben vous voyez, c'est le système belge qui ne fonctionne pas.
Donc, ils ont un avantage sur les autres partis dans la mesure où comme ils contestent le système, ben ils peuvent toujours dire que c'est le système qui ne marche pas.
Mais quand ils disent : Allez, on va quand même entrer dans le système et le faire fonctionner, ben voilà, ils ont cette possibilité-là aussi, alors que les autres,
n'ont pas cette dualité de, de, de positionnement qui fait qu'ils peuvent être un pied dedans, un pied dehors.
Donc, je pense qu'ils ont un avantage de ce côté-là. Je pense aussi que,
même si
on a pu considérer à l'époque que
le geste qui avait été commis
par Alexander De Croo de, de, de, de faire en sorte que son parti quitte le gouvernement était spectaculaire, de nature à attirer l'attention des électeurs sur son parti, de dénoncer un certain immobilisme.
Il faut bien voir que le sujet qui avait été choisi, c'était un sujet communautaire. Or, le communautaire, ce n'est absolument pas dans l'ADN de ce parti.
Ce n'est pas quelque chose avec lequel on identifie ce parti.
Et forcément, à ce moment-là, ça déforce aussi l'image parce que c'est un parti dont l'électorat est au contraire attaché à une certaine stabilité, qui est bonne pour le monde économique, c'est quand même son ADN, etc.
Alors qu'ici, la N-VA est quand même à provoquer une crise autour de quelque chose qui est dans, qui est devenu, en tout cas, parce que même si ça n'y figurait pas au départ, c'est une évolution qu'ils ont accompagnée,
qui est quand même au,
un des, des, des, des points d'identification de, de, de leur programme, c'est-à-dire toute la question de la migration.
Donc, ce n'est pas, ce n'est pas comme si c'était un sujet qui est presque aux antipodes de leurs préoccupations. Je crois qu'ils ont raison quand ils disent que c'est au cœur de leurs problématiques.
Maintenant, ce qu'ils ont dit du pacte, la façon dont ils l'ont présenté, la façon dont ils l'ont instrumentalisé ou utilisé dans une perspective électorale, ça, ça me semble tout à fait autre chose.
Qui sera sanctionné alors pour cette chute de gouvernement ? Est-ce que, est-ce que Charles Michel va perdre du point à cause de sa, entre guillemets, sa mauvaise gestion de, de, de la crise ?
Alors, c'est pas moi qui déciderai, ce sera-
Les électeurs, bien sûr. Mais qu'est-ce qu'on anticipe ?
Je pense que la difficulté pour Charles Michel et, et, et le MR,
dès lors qu'ils avaient pris
un pari qui était quand même énorme de faire ce gouvernement avec la N-VA en ayant dit qu'ils ne gouverneraient pas avec la N-VA, avec la N-VA et comme seul parti francophone,
je pense en effet que la manière dont le gouvernement
a terminé sa course, c'est-à-dire non pas le terme logique et normal de la législature, mais une crise, ça rend les choses plus compliquées pour justifier ce qu'ils ont fait et aussi pour dire ce qu'ils vont faire après.
Parce que maintenant, ils ont le problème de savoir sur quelle ligne ils se situent. Est-ce qu'ils veulent recommencer un gouvernement de droite ou de centre droit comme ça a été le cas ?
Mais est-ce que ce sera avec la N-VA ? Est-ce qu'ils ne vont pas retomber dans les mêmes, dans les mêmes difficultés ?
Il y a eu aussi un certain nombre de déclarations quand même très fortes, comme celle de la marionnette à laquelle vous faites allusion et qui laisse des traces qui vont pouvoir ressortir.
Donc, on n'est plus tout à fait dans le même cas de figure que l'autre fois. Ou alors, est-ce qu'ils veulent s'adresser, justement, faire un pas vers les partis de gauche ?
Mais ça va aussi à l'encontre de ce qu'ils ont fait pendant quatre ans. Donc, je pense qu'ils doivent, ils doivent en effet déterminer ce qui sera leur ligne et ce ne sera pas si facile que ça.
Ce qui est assez curieux, c'est que, voilà, je reviens encore une fois sur les déclarations de Jan Jambon, de Theo Francken et autres qui, qui flinguent un petit peu le Mouvement Réformateur, voilà, ces dernières semaines dans la presse.
Ce faisant,
est-ce qu'ils ne contribuent pas, voilà, à faire baisser le, le, l'électorat du Mouvement Réformateur en Belgique francophone et à mettre en difficulté un futur partenaire, un, oui, un futur partenaire aux élections de, de mai 2019 ?
C'est, c'est assez curieux.
Mais vous savez, les politiciens, ou les responsables politiques, puisqu'ils n'aiment pas ce terme de politiciens, ne sont pas toujours des gens qui sont uniquement dans la rationalité, dans le calcul, dans l'intérêt bien compris.
Ce sont parfois des gens qui se laissent emporter par leurs émotions, ils sont parfois à cran, ils sont parfois fatigués, ils dérapent-
Ça semble quand même très calculé.
Ils disent un certain nombre de choses et puis après, ils essayent de récupérer le coup. On n'est pas dans un monde où ce sont des robots.
Et donc c'est vrai qu'à partir du moment où il y a un certain nombre de déclarations qui affaibliraient leur seul partenaire du côté francophone, en tout cas qui a fait le pas, même si les autres ne l'excluent pas,
c'est peut-être pas dans leur intérêt, mais c'est peut-être dans leur intérêt de marquer aussi maintenant, au-delà des émotions ou, ou de l'air du temps, de marquer qu'ils n'ont pas voulu faire en sorte de,
de, d'obéir au, au MR, de danser comme le MR siffle, parce que c'était ce que disaient les responsables du, du Vlaams Belang à l'égard de la N-VA.
Donc, est-ce que c'est un calcul de positionnement ? Est-ce que c'est de la mauvaise humeur ou de l'amertume ou tout à la fois ?
Possible. Maintenant, en politique,
les déclarations,
bon, sont toujours prises avec une certaine distance. Il y a des ruptures en politique, hein,
mais en général, elles se situent à, à un autre niveau que celui des déclarations des uns ou des autres, parce qu'ils en font tous des déclarations
excessives à certains moments.
Question relativement technique sur laquelle, voilà, beaucoup s'interrogent. À votre avis, pourquoi est-ce que Charles Michel a pris la décision de présenter sa démission avant même que la motion de méfiance ne soit votée ?
Ben parce qu'il allait perdre.
Il, il le savait d'avance ?
Il le savait d'avance. À partir-- Il, il peut quand même calculer. Donc à partir du moment où il fait ses calculs, qu'il voit qu'il va perdre, ben plutôt que
de voir, dans-- et que ça serve dans des images archives, un tableau où l'on voit
les votes et où l'on voit qu'il a perdu, ben il préfère encore, à ce moment-là, plutôt que de subir une défaite
montrer qu'il prend quand même ses responsabilités et il décide lui-même de présenter la démission du gouvernement.
C'est une question de positionnement. C'est peut-être aussi une question de, de dignité personnelle ou en tout cas de volonté de ne pas paraître comme une victime expiatoire.
Sur la scène politique belge, je dois dire que le cas d'Ecolo-Groen me fascine complètement ces derniers mois. Donc on l'a vu aux élections communales, les écologistes ont, voilà, ils ont complètement le vent en poupe.
Selon les derniers sondages, il n'est même pas tout à fait impossible que, voilà, l'union franco-néerlandophone puisse dépasser la N-VA en nombre de sièges en 2019.
Ce n'est pas impossible. Et ce serait alors la première formation politique en Belgique. Ce nouvel électorat écolo, d'où vient-il ?
Alors, ce nouvel électorat écolo, il vient d'abord de la base d'Écolo, parce qu'Écolo a une base, même si leur électorat et leurs résultats électoraux ont, ont souvent beaucoup varié, il y a une base écologique qui existe.
C'est quand même un parti qui est arrivé sous la scène politique belge il y a plus de, plus de trente ans, hein, donc forcément-
Oui, enfin, passer du simple au double, c'est quand même remarquable.
Alors justement, justement, ce qui, ce qui peut se produire aussi actuellement,
c'est qu'il y a évolution, une évolution marquante, je dirais, de la population et de sa sensibilité par rapport au, au, au, au thème de l'environnement.
Et donc, je dirais que c'est évident que ça aide un parti dont c'est le combat premier et depuis toujours et qui est crédible sur le dossier.
Et à partir de ce moment-là, à partir du moment où justement la problématique devient maintenant transversale, à partir du moment où tous les partis disent que c'est important, ben il est normal que quelque part, cela favorise aussi
le passage vers Écolo.
Et moi, je pense que pour répondre pratiquement à votre question : d'où vient le nouvel électorat d'Écolo ? Quand un parti double ses voix, c'est que ce nouvel électorat, il vient de partout.
Il y avait une époque où Écolo clamait haut et fort qu'il préférait de toute façon former des coalitions avec la gauche de toute manière.
Aujourd'hui, ça semble un petit peu révolu et ils se sont, voilà, un petit peu ouverts sur la droite. On a vu, hein, à Uccle, à Woluwe, dans le Brabant wallon,
un électorat qui était historiquement complètement attaché au Mouvement réformateur qui délaisse le MR pour voter Écolo.
Mais par contre, ce que moi, je trouve absolument fascinant, c'est le cas de Forest et de Grez-Doiceau,
où Écolo était partant pour faire une coalition communale avec le Mouvement réformateur, mais la base militante, voilà, les militants écolos s'y sont opposés assez frontalement.
Est-ce qu'il n'y a pas finalement une certaine opposition entre la tête du parti qui veut s'ouvrir un petit peu à droite et la base du parti qui reste quand même très ancrée à gauche ?
Alors, plusieurs choses. Un : je pense que c'est tout à l'honneur d'un parti d'avoir une démocratie interne.
Et donc, si à un certain moment, la base n'est pas d'accord avec ce que ses représentants ont décidé ou négocié ou proposé, eh bien voilà, c'est la démocratie du parti, tant mieux.
Deuxièmement, ce que je crois aussi, c'est que
les bases des partis sont souvent plus radicales que le sommet.
Parce que dans le sommet, on est obligé de trouver en effet des compromis, de rencontrer d'autres gens,
alors qu'à la base, on a des gens qui sont moins dans ces jeux de pouvoir et qui sont plus axés sur les questions de, de principe parce que ce sont des gens engagés,
ce sont des gens qui sont des militants, mais c'est valable pour tous les partis hein.
La base est souvent, pas toujours, souvent plus radicale, plus engagée, moins prompte à faire des compromis que le sommet.
Et la troisième chose que je voudrais dire, c'est que paradoxalement, mais ça peut être une raison pour expliquer ça aussi, c'est qu'il y a, il peut y avoir une certaine proximité
sociologique entre les libéraux et les écologistes hein.
Ce sont des gens avec un certain niveau de, de formation, certain, un certain revenu peut-être aussi,
et il peut y avoir, je dirais, une opposition à l'intérieur de, de ce même groupe entre, entre des gens plus, plus conservateurs et d'autres plus progressistes qui font qu'il y a peut-être une méfiance,
de la part de, d'une partie de la base d'Écolo de voir comme ça
d'autres gens, d'autres gens arriver et peut-être une certaine méfiance par rapport à,
à, à ces nouveaux électeurs ou à cette nouveau, nouvelle couche qui pourrait faire pencher la balance à l'intérieur, à l'intérieur du parti.
Oui. Donc, à vous entendre, les écologistes sont presque plus proches, en tout cas à un niveau sociologique, démographique, sont peut-être plus proches des libéraux qu'ils ne le sont des socialistes.
Alors, de nouveau, je ne suis pas sociologue et il y a sûrement des études à faire par rapport au dernier scrutin.
Là, on, on pourrait l'analyser,
mais je pense en effet, et ça fait déjà-- et ça, ça a déjà été démontré depuis pratiquement le, le début de l'arrivée des écologistes sur
sur la scène politique, que, par exemple, il y a une très grande proximité entre l'électorat d'Écolo et celui du CDH, par exemple, ou en tout cas une partie du CDH,
notamment là plus en termes d'origines socioculturelles marquées par des courants religieux, etc.
Mais il peut y avoir aussi, il peut y avoir aussi une plus grande proximité avec certains, avec certaines sphères dans le Mouvement réformateur.
Dans le Brabant wallon, les deux plus grands partis, c'est le MR et Écolo.
Face à ce constat que le Parti Écolo a vraiment le vent en poupe, qu'il pique quelques électeurs ou de nombreux électeurs au Mouvement Réformateur, est-ce que vous pensez que le Mouvement Réformateur va
adapter sa stratégie, son positionnement et peut-être retourner à des racines plus libérales, contrairement au positionnement peut-être un peu plus conservateur qu'il a pu montrer ce mandat-ci ?
Est-ce que vous pensez que c'est quelque chose qu'on va pouvoir observer ?
Le Mouvement Réformateur est face à
un choix idéologique qui ne sera pas simple, j'y ai déjà fait allusion.
C'est qu'on voit bien qu'en faisant cette coalition avec la N-VA, en étant seul parti au pouvoir et en menant une politique de centre-droit, voire de droite, je laisse à chacun
le soin d'apprécier le terme qui convient le mieux, il s'est coupé d'une partie de son électorat qui est sans doute plus ouvert sur certaines autres thématiques, qui a pu être choqué aussi par des positions radicales sur la question de la migration.
Ils ont perdu sur leur gauche et notamment des électeurs qui ont pu passer chez Ecolo, ça, je pense que c'est assez clair, mais en même temps, et on le voit bien dans la popularité qu'a pu avoir Theo Francken en Wallonie ou à Bruxelles,
ils ont aussi, et même si ça se recrutait peut-être dans tous les partis, ils ont aussi des gens qui
soutiennent cette politique qui a été menée.
Et donc, s'ils se déplacent
trop à gauche, ils risquent de perdre un certain nombre de gens sur leur droite. Et c'est là qu'est la difficulté pour eux, c'est de savoir quel va être ce message qu'ils vont pouvoir adresser aux électeurs de manière à fédérer différents courants.
Maintenant, c'est quelque chose qui concerne tous les grands partis. Tous les grands partis sont confrontés évidemment à des courants différents, à des électeurs variés.
Même la N-VA, dans la N-VA, il y a aussi un courant plus proche des milieux de l'entreprise. Il y a aussi un courant plus identitaire, plus proche du Vlaams Belang.
Il y a aussi un courant qui est plus axé sur les questions communautaires et il faut aussi les faire coexister. Ce n'est jamais simple.
Ce n'est jamais simple, mais évidemment, pour le MR, vu la position qu'il a prise la dernière fois et la manière dont les choses se sont terminées, il va falloir faire un choix.
J'évoquais tout à l'heure les relations parfois un petit peu tendues entre la base électorale, les militants du Parti Écolo et le Mouvement Réformateur.
J'en ai consulté certains et ce n'est clairement pas un parti qu'ils estiment très chaleureusement. Compte tenu de cette situation-là, est-ce qu'on est en capacité d'imaginer une coalition orange, bleue, verte ?
En Belgique, on est en capacité d'envisager tout. Donc ça, il faut, à certaines exceptions près, je ne crois pas que le Vlaams Belang va arriver au pouvoir après les prochaines élections fédérales.
Je ne pense pas non plus que le PTB fera partie de la prochaine coalition. Mais à part ces deux extrêmes-là, et je ne les mets pas sur le même pied, forcément, je pense que beaucoup de choses sont possibles.
Et d'ailleurs, vous y avez fait référence, on voit bien qu'au niveau communal, il y a des majorités très différentes qui ont été formées.
Et donc oui, c'est possible aussi qu'on se retrouve avec des majorités très diverses, que ce soit en Flandre, que ce soit en Wallonie ou à Bruxelles.
Il faut savoir aussi qu'en Flandre, Groen est au pouvoir avec la N-VA dans pas mal de communes. On n'imagine pas du tout ça du côté francophone, mais ça existe.
Et il faut savoir que même à Anvers, dans les jours qui ont suivi
la démission de la N-VA du gouvernement fédéral et après des déclarations quand même extrêmement radicales sur le pacte des migrations, les socialistes et la N-VA
sont arrivés à un compromis pour la gestion de la ville qui, au moment où on se parle, n'a pas encore été formellement validé par les partis et par les bases, mais pourrait l'être.
On sait que le gouvernement Charles Michel a été critiqué par certains pour son bilan au niveau climatique. Hier, à la Chambre des représentants a été votée justement une résolution pour renforcer le mandat de la Belgique pour la COP 24.
Un aspect qui m'a particulièrement surpris et que soulignait la ministre Marghem, il y a quelques jours, c'est que mardi, jour de la démission de Charles Michel, au matin, Ecolo soutenait une motion de recommandation pour justement
que le gouvernement s'engage davantage dans la lutte climatique.
Et puis l'après-midi, le soir, Ecolo cosignait une motion de méfiance. C'est quand même assez curieux, non ?
C'est assez curieux, mais je suis sûr que vous pouvez trouver des attitudes aussi sinueuses dans tous les partis entre le moment où les ministres N-VA ont quitté le gouvernement et le moment où Charles Michel présente sa démission.
Je trouve d'ailleurs que, mais c'est facile à dire quand on n'est pas aux affaires et c'est facile à dire rétrospectivement, je ne pense pas qu'on a beaucoup gagné à cette période.
Je pense qu'il est normal que Charles Michel, à la fois pour des raisons personnelles comme Premier ministre, aussi
a essayé de sauver son gouvernement, mais à partir du moment où il n'y est pas arrivé, il aurait peut-être été plus simple qu'au moment où il y avait une démission,
forcée ou pas des ministres N-VA, le gouvernement présente sa démission au roi et que l'on voit après comment on peut fonctionner.
Parce que je ne pense pas que, à cause justement de toutes, de tous ces virages pris par les différents partis, ces déclarations qui pouvaient paraître contradictoires et le côté quand même compliqué, c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire,
de toutes,
les arcanes institutionnelles qui faisaient que même les constitutionnalistes n'étaient pas d'accord entre eux.
Je suis pas sûr que ce soit, que ça a été de nature à faire en sorte que la population se sente concernée par la politique.
Au contraire, je pense que ça a contribué sans doute à ce que le monde politique ait une image d'un groupe de gens préoccupés par eux-mêmes-
C'est ça, les petits jeux de politiciens.
Déconnectés
et qui ne s'intéressent pas vraiment
aux gens. Donc, rétrospectivement, je pense quand même qu'il aurait mieux valu qu'il y ait une démission et puis que les partis ensemble voient vers quoi on allait,
soit des élections anticipées, soit un gouvernement d'affaires courantes jusqu'en mai,
mais sans passer par cette case qui n'aura quand même rien apporté de positif.
Très bien. Alain Gerlache, on va clôturer là-dessus. Merci beaucoup.
Avec plaisir.
Et chers auditeurs, on vous souhaite de joyeuses fêtes et à dans deux semaines. Au revoir. C'est déjà tout pour ces Septante Minutes avec Alain Gerlache.
On a enregistré cet épisode au milieu du patio radio de la RTBF, donc il y avait beaucoup de bruit ambiant autour de nous.
J'ai fait mon possible pour le supprimer. Voilà, vous me direz si la qualité du son vous a posé problème.
Mais surtout, et ceux qui suivent l'émission sur Twitter le savent, au bout des septante minutes, mon enregistreur a fait un joli message d'erreur bien inquiétant, un magnifique data write error.
Et là, je vais pas vous dire que j'aurais pu tomber dans les pommes, mais voilà, on n'était pas, on n'était pas très loin.
Heureusement, l'intégralité de l'enregistrement était intacte. Donc voilà, ceux qui ont vu mon tweet, soyez rassurés.
D'ailleurs, vous avez écouté l'émission, vous le savez, tout s'est bien passé. Youpi
! Pour ceux que ça intéresse, à l'issue de l'enregistrement, on a appris que le roi avait accepté la démission de Charles Michel et que le gouvernement fédéral était maintenant entré en affaires courantes.
Donc autrement dit, il est maintenant un peu dans un état végétatif.
Un parti qui n'est pas du tout dans un état végétatif, ce sont les Écologistes dont on a beaucoup parlé avec Alain Gerlache, parti qui a vraiment le vent en poupe, comme on le disait, et qui a surpris tout le monde en cette fin d'année.
Et d'ailleurs, il se pourrait que j'aie déjà fixé un rendez-vous au Parlement fédéral avec un député écolo. Voilà, c'est possible.
C'est pas... voilà, il paraît. Il paraît que ça a été fait. Je vous dis à dans deux semaines pour un troisième épisode centré sur la politique belge.
Et puis après ça, normalement, on passera à autre chose. Pour ne pas manquer les prochains épisodes, je vous invite à vous abonner à Septante Minutes Avec sur les réseaux sociaux, sur YouTube, sur Spotify, sur iTunes,
sur Pocket Cast, sur tout ce que vous voulez.
Tous les liens sont dans la description. Et je vous dis à dans deux semaines. Bye bye.